joining me right now is a pro football
hall of famer in
that wing of uh of the
of the great hall in canton ohio from
nbc sports and um and um the uh football
morning in america column that you can
catch on pro football talk is a great
peter king how are you pk
hey rich how are you doing i'm i'm well
i i opened the show today peter with
uh the details of what is to me and i've
been fortunate to now this is my 19th
season with nfl network since leaving
espn and doing that
i don't remember a week like this and i
know that there's such a thing as parody
but the week itself with the headlines
leading up and then the results
uh of the weekend is this the craziest
week you've ever seen peter i know
that's hyperbole but i'll give you the
floor on it i think it i think it is
rich because
uh first of all
it's uh it was a huge week for
on the week of the trading deadline for
who was traded
von miller and who was not you know
desean watson and odell beckham uh was a
big week because beckham basically now
has
has talked his way out of cleveland and
will go play for somebody else
and now we'll find out if he is a shell
of his former self
or whether he's still got a lot of good
football left
and it was a big weekend because of the
whole aaron rodgers thing uh certainly
and also because of
one of the biggest tragedies involving
an nfl player
certainly in the 38 seasons i've been
covering the game
i don't remember something that is as
sort of as heinous and as
uh
reprehensible as somebody driving 156
miles an hour on city streets
in an american city and
then slamming into another vehicle and
basically incinerating a woman and her
dog in the other vehicle
uh and it isn't the
the other part of that story that i
wrote a little bit about today
is just that
you know if you look at
what uh henry ruggs was
he was basically
uh kind of the crown jewel of mike mayox
rebuilding
of the las vegas raiders and now
he's just gone it's amazing that the
last month
uh
just overnight in a matter of
of seconds really
the head coach and the most promising
uh
skill player
on the las vegas raiders
who are still a first place team by the
way just vanished
they just vanished they're gone
with no time to prepare
for how to adjust to life without them
so
it's just this has been a crazy week and
it's been a crazy time period in the nfl
and then you can
also throw in there the uh
the trading away of uh um a crown jewel
of a franchise john elway's first draft
choice with denver super bowl mvp of
super bowl 50 the the milestone super
bowl mvp to los angeles and the rams
don't play him because he's not healthy
enough yet they lose to a titan's team
that loses derek henry and then puts
adrian peterson in who scores and they
win
you know
um jordan loves loved ones in the last
row of a stadium the jaguars beating the
bills honestly it's really and the
cardinals doing what they did the saints
coming back from 18 down
uh 22 point fourth quarter and they
still lose at the last second
i honestly don't remember anything like
this nothing but what about the josh
allen on josh allen crosstalk there's
another one you know and the jaguars win
their first game on american soil in 420
days
uh don't score a touchdown uh they lost
for a second their their crown jewel at
quarterback he comes back in the game
it's
i honestly i i
that's why one of one of many reasons
why i haven't spoken in a while have you
on is just to put it in perspective uh
what what have we learned from this week
or is this just a one of those bury the
game film because the broncos the
broncos after losing von miller trading
him away they they boat race the cowboys
almost damn shut them out
i mean that should have been a shutout i
mean mike mccarthy in my opinion
you know just put dak prescott who
is coming off a calf injury anyway so
weird
you know please put him in the cupboard
until next game you've lost this one
um but but i say you know last night i
was sitting down to write and uh a head
coach in the nfl you know sits down and
and
you know because i was texting back and
forth about what a crazy day it was and
he basically said
every week in the nfl is like this i
wish i had the quote in front of me i
don't but every week in the nfl is like
this every week
is almost
a season in and of itself and rich and
that's why
to me
i'm not saying that you don't
pay attention to a week like this when
you're thinking about well who's good
and who's not good
but i also think that you can't allow
one week
for you to say well
i was wrong about the bills they stink i
i was wrong about the rams they can't
play a physical style and and beat a
good team and then i was wrong about
this team and wrong about that
you know the fact is i covered the
raiders and the giants on sunday in the
meadowlands
and the fact is
uh derrick carr
has had uh has had two lousy games this
year played lousy against the bears
uh in vegas and he was really lousy
yesterday uh he overthrew wide open
darren waller in the end zone
uh under through zay jones the the
replacement for for 10 minutes for henry
ruggs until they traded for desean
jackson which we didn't even mention
right or until they signed them uh and
and but but be that as it may the point
is
i still think the raiders are pretty
good
and so i just don't think in today's nfl
you can allow one game one week
to skew what you've seen for eight weeks
and and i guess just to put a bow on it
peter king i mean if you had to guess if
you if you knew what was happening this
week and you could have chosen your bye
week for this year i would have chosen
week nine and the bucks sit at this one
out and the packers cowboys rams and
saints all lose i mean what a
what a great week feet up you know
smoke them if you got them you know yeah
well what a week for them to sit out the
weird the weird part too that
you know and again let's get political
um the weird part of this week too is
that obviously i think we all think
that if aaron rodgers plays in that game
in kansas city yesterday no doubt
there's a 90
chance the packers win
uh and so
i mean that was the first time yesterday
in more than four years
that
uh that devante adams
didn't catch at least half of the balls
thrown to him
and
you know look jordan love at least right
now and who knows what the future holds
he's not an accurate enough passer
uh to scare any defense
and and that's why to me
look
if a quarterback who is unvaccinated
test positive
on a friday for covid
he misses two games
now aaron rodgers is fortunate he tested
positive on a wednesday right
so
assuming
that next saturday morning at lambeau
field when he goes into
uh you know get his covet test assuming
he tests negative
and that may be a bad assumption but i
would assume he would test negative and
if he does
then uh he'll he'll play against seattle
on sunday setting up a game that i
believe russell wilson is going to play
so instead of having
gino smith versus jordan love it looks
like we could have
russell wilson versus aaron rodgers and
hopefully we get to lose ourselves and
all of that and enjoy the football peter
king here on the rich eisen show what
did happen with odell in cleveland
what's your best sense on what actually
did happen
there you know i talked to a coach this
weekend who i think is interested in
odell beckham and they've
they spent some time late in the week
watching him on tape and they didn't
think he was a disciplined root runner
and that he has lost
uh that aspect especially if you're in
what you might consider precision
offense and look
there's a lot of quarterbacks in the nfl
who
uh basically need you to be at a certain
spot
and are going to kind of throw it to
that spot so you better be there
uh yeah for instance if if he went to
tampa bay tom brady is famous for
you know having a trust with his
receivers and look
i think if odell beckham jr went to
tampa bay and i doubt he will but i
think if he did
then he would get it straight right away
hey listen
if you're not in the spot that i'm going
to throw to i'll give you a couple of
chances but if you're not there i'm not
throwing it to you anymore
and
my pet theory although i certainly
haven't studied tape the way a scout
would my pet theory is that that's why
the browns uh may have gone away from
baker mafia or gone away from odell
beckham if indeed that is the case
but i also think rich that
there are times when removing someone
from a team and from an organization
is a positive no matter how good he is
or no matter how much of an impact
player you thought he was when you
traded for him in my opinion uh you know
this was
i'm not saying long overdue but this was
overdue
uh this was a guy who just simply was
not happy was not getting the ball
and it's all well and good to say
man this guy can can ruin a defense and
all that stuff i mean
when is the last time you've seen odell
beckham jr
uh you know play a great football game
i'll tell you when it was it was over a
year ago when cleveland went to dallas
and he scored a couple of touchdowns and
was
you know just a huge factor all over the
field
then he gets the knee injury and this
whole year he's not been impactful at
all so
i think it's overdue what the browns did
so we're assuming he's going to fall
through waivers that the the contract
will be significant enough
um to have him fall through waivers then
then what
give us the the overthrow you know rich
i think
the logical landing spots for him
among others uh seattle is one i know
russell wilson really wants him there uh
but russell wilson has said that he
wants a lot of players there he wanted
antonio brown and they didn't get him
and
the josh gordon experiment with a little
more than a cup of coffee
so i know seattle
there's some sentiment that seattle will
look at them and and obviously
it ought to be
uh but you wonder with the problems
they're having at quarterback do they
want to add a squeaky wheel
to that team plus the fact that
new orleans has less than no money
and so
i think that's going to be an issue
if odell beckham jr really wants to go
play in new orleans
they probably can figure a way to make
it happen but he's going to have to play
for no money
and i don't know that i and i have no
idea
what the
odell beckham jr side is is expecting as
far as financial uh remuneration but i
don't think they're going to get much
money out of the same yeah i know
obviously if jameis was there he might
say
why not and obviously playing for sean
payton is without question something
that i think would entice um but you
know trevor simeon did struggle for
three plus quarters in in um in in new
orleans this past week so what about
green bay is that total pie in the sky
insanity doesn't fit their offense don't
want them i mean wouldn't you think that
rogers
um
i think it's a great i think it's a
great concept you know theoretic in
theory right um
and again
i think it really depends on what you
think about him as a football player
um
and it wouldn't surprise me if they're
studying odell beckham jr very hard
there right um but i i and again i don't
mean to be on the brian gutican's
bandwagon here
but
their problems
when aaron rodgers is on the field
aren't that they're not scoring enough
and it'd be great to have another weapon
i just wonder what they're gonna see
what they're gonna see when they put on
the tape
so where do you think he winds up i mean
wouldn't you know i i don't know if i
had to if i had to guess
i would say new orleans because it's
clearly where he wants to go okay
uh or one of the places that he really
wants to go
but i i don't know rich i'd be
absolutely guessing and uh that would be
my guess ask peter king the poll
question as we send him out uh on his
merry monday chris brockman go for it
all right peter here's what we got which
team took a step back from what you
thought of them before week nine
bengals bills cowboys rams those are
four bury the tape type performances of
those teams in week nine what do you
think well well
i'd say probably the bengals because
look two weeks ago i had the anointing
oils out for cincinnati
and i thought that they were going to
there certainly would be a playoff team
and they might even win their division
then they lose to the jets and it's easy
to say well that's just one week road
game weird things happen there
they got throttled by the browns
and burrow for the second straight week
didn't play well now i love joe burrow
i think joe burrow is going to be great
for a long time
but when he doesn't play well
that team is just not very good it's
almost to the level of
uh aaron rodgers not being there when
when borough doesn't play well they
don't have a great chance to win
and so i think that game
even though i didn't necessarily think
they were going to beat the browns
just getting throttled by him uh it just
really surprised me i mean the addition
by subtraction i guess that odell was uh
that
that was something else huh
right from that performance but i think
i think a lot of times
if you take away
a player on your team who for whatever
reason right is dragging you down
and
either
because he's in the huddle negative
energy not getting the ball throwing his
hands in the air doing whatever if you
have that on your team you're better off
saying hey donovan peoples jones
i need you to be
an excellent number two for the rest of
the year
and he started the show yesterday that
he can be one so let's see what happens
but i think
there is a little bit more peace and
prosperity
on the browns both in the locker room
and and on the field yesterday and we'll
see if that lasts peter thanks for the
time i knew your perspective would be
just what the doctor ordered here man i
mean i i honestly from this
at this one week ago today is when we
learned von miller literally one week
ago at this point in times when we
learned von miller is on the move and
then the rest of it just went uh off
off-center to say the least yeah it was
a it was a kilter it was a fun week but
i i i'd really appreciate a quieter one
take care of yourself p.k thanks for
coming
the one and only peter king everybody
should check out his football morning in
america column profootballtalk.com
nbcsports.com
right here hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here